[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
MAN 1: Morocco,
it's off the map.
No one would know about it.
This was a place where
he could test himself,
both physically and mentally
with a massive amount
of climbing.
And then, he wanted to free
solo one of the big walls
at the end of the trip.
He knew that the
route that he'd chosen
would be one of the greatest
big wall free solos in history.
MAN 2: I can't wait to
sign all of this stuff.
I'm so curious if we can
actually make these walls feel
smaller, you know?
TOMMY CALDWELL: Yeah.
There's baby goats halfway
up the first pitch.
That's really cute.
MAN 2: Tommy was really
the only possible partner
for the training that I was
hoping to do in Morocco.
We all just like to climb with
somebody who climbs so fast.
Like, so amazing.
Tommy Is one of the
best in the world.
When I started
climbing, he was already
a hero in the climbing
world, and I looked up to him
my entire life.
TOMMY CALDWELL: I
think Alex and I just
felt like if we got
together and climbed,
we could do stuff that we
couldn't do on our own.
And from there, it evolved into
this very close friendship.
They're only going
to bring in 5.
MAN 2: And so knowing that
he had this giant objective,
my role just became to help
him survive, essentially.
MAN 1: Tommy didn't
want Alex to free solo,
but he knew that Alex was
going to go do it anyways.
So Tommy decides
that the best way
that he can support his
friend is to train with him.
TOMMY CALDWELL: Doing
something that dangerous
is really about
having full confidence
that you will be successful.
MAN 1: Alex wanted
to push himself
with a huge endurance
challenge, a triple linkup.
To climb 3 of the biggest walls
in Tajia with Tommy in one day.
It would be the
equivalent of running
three back-to-back marathons
at a world record pace.
MAN 3: So what's
your guess on time?
TOMMY CALDWELL: 22 hours.
MAN 3: 22.
MAN 2: I think like 5:00 AM.
So that means that we'd
be doing 21 hour link-up.
That's my prediction.
MAN 3: All right.
Let's see who's closest.
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
MAN 2: OK, lav, good to go.
MAN 1: These big walls are
extraordinarily technical.
This is 512, 513 terrain.
A rating of difficulty
that really only a world
class climber can climb.
MAN 2: I remember sort of
not really loving this pitch.
TOMMY CALDWELL: I don't remember
this pitch hardly at all
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
[BLEEP] My finger slipped.
But it was a hard move.
The hardest move of the route.
I knew Alex was going to
free solo one of the routes
we were climbing together.
Thinking about
being up there, that
high off the ground
without a rope,
that's a terrifying thought.
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
Oh, god.
MAN 2: Hey, dude.
TOMMY CALDWELL: Oh god.
So fun climbing like that.
MAN 2: Pretty solid.
We did 6 and 1/2.
TOMMY CALDWELL: 6 and 1/2.
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]